and uh take care and
be sure to write huh you too
[Music]
blake lively's dad beloved actor ernie
lively has died he was 74 years old
a representative for the late star
confirmed the news to e.t
on wednesday revealing in a statement
quote yes
sadly ernie passed away the dukes of
hazzard actor reportedly died
last week in los angeles of cardiac
complications
according to the hollywood reporter
ernie was surrounded by his wife and
five children when he died i grew up
watching him and going to his auditions
and coaching him and i never wanted to
act
so it was nice i was coaching him and
picking out his outfits when i was like
5.
ernie's career spanned 50 years and over
110
credits his first role was on the 1975
series the waltons
he went on to nab parts in shows like
hanging with mr cooper
the x-files the west wing that 70s show
and
more how much fun is it to sort of work
together on a movie like that well how
often do you get to do that
i mean especially with i've worked with
a lot of beautiful women none more
pretty than this
and it's the most special thing you
could ever imagine
in 2005's the sisterhood of the
traveling pants
ernie played his real-life daughter
blake's father on screen
a role he reprised in the film's sequel
you hungry
one slice favorite recipe
uh no it's okay eight on the road the
actor married talent manager elaine
lively in 1979
and welcomed two kids together blake and
eric lively
he adopted elaine's three children lori
robin and jason
from her previous marriage
[Music]
you